hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm ryan
shoes ryan shoes is it's two O's not an
E
no shoes no shoes ulis Shh hmm let's go
back and forth you know anyway uh you
might recognize Ryan from a movie called
the gallows it's a horror film that came
out from this company called blue house
nobody Warner Brothers did it or it's
not a big deal do you know about them
I've heard of the brothers yeah not that
familiar with them they're good guys
yeah kidding you all know those [ __ ]
are anyway guys I'm actually going to be
going out to Fresno California to check
out the haunted mansion or maze right
based off the gallows mansion I think
it's a mansion right I think so yeah and
I figured you know what I know Ryan
Gallo's so he should come on it'll spawn
yeah right Alice will never call you
shoes
yo gallows gallows what's up man I have
this image I don't think this would ever
happen but I have this image that like
you don't book anything for like 10
years and I'm like hey you're Ryan
gallows a book in sick of that movie
yeah why didn't you contact me earlier
ten years ago five day so we're gonna
check out the second trailer for creed I
want to see this movie Michael B Jordan
you're clearly a fan of the guy he's
shredded and yeah that's why I'll read
even like by I love the rocky franchise
I'm excited to see like this different
take this way they're spinning off the
Rocky movie shirt and it's cool that
Stallone's willing to like hand it off
at least that's what it looks like he's
doing and I just saw south bar recently
oh I heard that was pretty good I love a
good boxing will unfortunately miss it a
good boxing movies a damn good movie if
it's cliche I like I like a punch
everyone hunted out it like the Rocky
punch the rocky punches were are amazing
because when rocky gets hit you as an
audience member you feel it yeah yeah
every time he gets hit you're like no
and then he hits back you're like yeah
he can take more punches than any human
on this planet why his brain to boot
that's my stolen impression pills the
just alone Oh thought that was
Stallone's here yeah I know it's it's I
know that's why no trailer - he's right
over here
we have to separate his fight with the
other my lights hey Danny
your father was a great man to me I
don't know have I got nothin doing me
well I think you could be a great to my
brothers what the third one is your
faith the pot was fired
dad before I was born bounced around
foster care and then out of juvie
I'm gonna fight in my whole life it's
not a choice thing you just got here
staring back at you pick your toughest
opponent who's next
oh I leave this jewelry and I think
that's true life so
so he can relieve me too yeah you know
how many times I had to care with a
heavyweight champion we will up these
stairs because he couldn't walk ribs
broken nose broken eyes swollen shut
how do you feel I'm afraid of taking on
the name losing call me a fraud you
still caught me shadows I removed it I
made every punch that I throw and
there's gonna compare the hell wall
Apollo Creed's son so use the name it's
yours
this kids being always never face nobody
you'll know nothing about me you are
false teeth you do this you're going
into a storm
let's watch hey meow rocky sick I found
the dog is my break
are you gonna fix it everything I got is
moved on and I'm here see they're crying
about nobody's around for you I'm in for
you every day
I'm staying right in front of you just
like any other fight so if I fight you
fight
I bow no
brings back everything as ever all the
pain I had inside they don't know what
we've been through
yeah grab one of these birdy sir I am
serious
chickens are slowing down ha ha slowed
up ding ding man I got chills I'm gonna
go to the gym now yeah
I'll seal it uh I know there's your
first time on the channel cake can I
just get your hand for one second my
hand yeah you feel it
it's an erect nipple whoo that is chills
my friends real that movie looks [ __ ]
sweet all right so I saw the first
trailer of that yeah and I was like okay
that one Holy Smoke epic man it looks
like a like a [ __ ] like character
study of this guy to you if I fight
you've a fight oh man punch for punch
dang dude my heart's racin it's like in
the rocky universe but it really feels
like its own movie I know I think we got
a new thing here it once I come out ah
let's see all 2015 coming out soon
we're in fall right now 2015 I got next
year yeah Michael B Jordan looks like
he's rocking like such a physically
demanding role oh no like he's like in
the hospital I love he's doing like push
flautist yeah man that's gonna breast
clap push-ups like you tell he really
got in like he looks like a legit boxer
in this film and the fight sequences
look cool there's a different kind of
direction towards like the Rocky movies
tend to have like a very I would say
kind of a light-hearted vibe to it you
know definitely had some grit ya know
there's red there's darkness and I'm
really liking it at first I was like all
right there's cliches I've been to juvie
yeah but then as a little bit stuff yeah
I know oh my god I love that that's a
story of redemption and not living in
someone else's shed
that's really it looks like a different
cuz the Rocky movies are inspiring this
looks like a different kind of
inspirational tale but they're not
losing that essence of inspiring boxing
movie for sure I kind of wish you didn't
show Stallone going to the hospital and
[ __ ] like I was like come on man but
that's gonna be his fight ya know yeah
you just move me on that yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] that's his father that's
that one that I really got my heart
deucey yeah this is nothing but fight
fight fight dude a little green dude
Poli dude I think my nipple backhand
with a guy wait girls get uh mm babe
they've always refused blood splatter
there's blood splatter and stuff like
this is stuff I'm like yeah you get that
in the Rocky movies but this is like in
a gritty way they're doing it but this
took tributes to the rocky stuff still
work you know like I just love how
Stallone is really willing to let rocky
be a supporting player yes you know he's
not yet trying to take the lead he's not
trying to steal the show you could tell
he's there to support Michael B Jordan
in this adventure it's time for the next
leg it's time for the next leg yeah I
wonder if I can play Michael B Jordan
son for the next one I don't know but I
did see that was New Line Cinema's as
well who also was in the gals involved
in the gallop really yeah so you should
probably get like a screening to this
you want to go hey guys Warner Brothers
a new line we're interested in seeing
your movie I'll be there we'll see if we
can get him on all the training
sequences look [ __ ] exciting too you
know like those monta that is rocky yeah
Rocky is Maserati is montage train every
Rocky movie has to have a montage Train
see if I hear done I don't think you
would work for this you imagine it
doesn't seem like you've it actually
worked and unless I get some type of
like like weird and remakes her like
little subtle I'm sure they'll do yeah
there has to be something Michael B
Jordans character looks much more
emotional than rocky because Rocky's
kind of always been like a little down
and kind of to himself Michael B Jordan
the Apollo Creed's son is like really
emotional and stuff and I know he can
hold the part from Fruitvale station
exactly it's the same director like yeah
they probably work better together by
now like he's evolved as an actor he's
evolved as a director now you're putting
both like that's an awesome way to
reunite them and I'm actually like
genuinely really excited for this film
it looks like a cool
in boxing movie fall 2015 mmm
that's today's somewhere around now
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe to the real rejects Ryan like
I said he's in the gallows the gallows
is being released on October 13th keep a
lookout for that downloaded illegally
don't rent it don't buy it there's ways
to get it for free well I'll give you a
copy
yeah he'll give you buy you a copy
totally into that yeah I got a costume
you see like ten bucks four bucks
four bucks dollar fifty cents so they
could pay for practically nothing for it
okay I'll sign it they will appreciate
that I keep a lookout for my vlog when I
go to Fresno you might be there too yeah
so keep a lookout for the vlog when I go
there and the haunted mansion the
Haunted Mansion that's what I'm talking
about the blog for the haunted mansion
do you have like social network pages
too yes my name Ryan shoes sh o o s at
Facebook
Ryan shoes Instagram Ryan shoes Twitter
Ryan ships yes and you follow me on
those as well and periscope and vine too
Adrian Daniel Marroquin what's up real
rejects family you're American
what did I say maduk win oh sorry Adrian
carries the atrium toils
what's up real rejects family your
channel is [ __ ] dope I love getting
high God not know that was a nice sense
and watching your videos deuces my
ninjas Adrian Daniel metal Queen dude
you [ __ ] rock man
listen weed don't let what anyone says
put you down keep getting stoned you
know getting stoned gets stoned right
now yeah I hope you're high right now I
know I am weed makes this channel way
better
we'd make weed makes filming this
channel way better weed makes him better
yeah no one likes me when I'm not high
well I attest to that an Adrian dude
let's see what you look like real fast I
don't know why but like 90% of the
subscribers look like future serial
killers you'd like that right now dawg
he looks like a serial joke everyone own
man maybe Oh me yeah maybe it won't look
like such as killer if you if you're
high in the video that's just nasty
Mickey's set of four oh you look like a
gangster oh [ __ ] body pic what a Michael
Beach sorry man people are gonna have to
see this photo now you just saved it oh
yeah
take care Adrian shout-out to you enjoy
ladies